[Music]
[Music]
the evil within the disturbing new
experience from the father of survival
horror Shinji Mikami takes us into the
twisted world of detective Sebastian
Castellanos as he unravels the horrific
details of who or what is terrorizing
crimson city
what I am
weapons and ammunition are a luxury when
you cannot always depend on when
confronting the haunted
and out of ammo
not having to make your disposal can
turn what should have been a quick kill
into a run for your life staying hidden
in the shadows may save your life and
give you the upper hand when ammo is
running low the evil within is a living
nightmare of sinister creatures
unforgiving environments and lethal
traps meant to capture name and kill
you'll need to be creative and figure
out how to turn obstacles into asset
while sometimes your enemies may appear
to be dead it's best to make absolutely
sure
the world there are points where
Sebastian can access a safe haven known
as the asylum you're always welcome here
it is in this mysterious place that he
can operate his weapons abilities and
inventory these upgrades will help you
with your survival without them you're
as good as dead
to solve the mysteries of a city where
everything has gone wrong you'll need to
survive
first and foremost but learning the
tools of the trade will only help your
chances because you'll need more than
bullets if you're going to make it out
alive